what do you think what's going on with
Kanye what do you I mean he said a lot
of different things but why why was this
the Tipping Point what do you think
about what's going on with them well you
know what I I mean again
getting into mental illness I don't
excuse behavior for mental illness and I
also I'm a Jew
um but as a Jew I don't want to make
this only about Jews because I think
this country is becoming so polarized
with everything and anytime someone
speaks like this everybody should speak
up whether it's about Muslims whether
it's about police officers it's all the
same stuff and and so what do I think is
going on with Kanye I think he's having
some type of bipolar episode but who
gives a [ __ ] it's like you know he's he
and again you know somehow this became a
free speech issue speak all you want and
everybody else should speak also and I
should have the right to not buy your
[ __ ] crappy sneakers and do whatever
else but um you know it's it's sad to
see because what what happens is and I
see it I have a lot of friends who are
police officers in L.A and this real
world consequences to this stuff kids
get threatened at schools and some guy
walking down the street gets punched in
the face and and um Nazis are on the 405
so again end though just separating it
from because I don't want to just make
it all about his comments about Jews
it's just you know like we're in this
we're in this place right now in the
state where everybody wants to make the
groups even worse and I swear to you
it's so nuts that 10 years ago I thought
my kids were gonna be in a colorblind
world I really was stupid enough to
believe in the last three years we have
gone backwards in ways that is is quite
frightening you think so yeah oh yeah
tell me why how do we get there I think
the media I think the media you watch
both sides of it I mean CNN will put
every single day how racist the country
is how awful cops are and you know of
course there are bad cops there's bad
everything there's bad football players
like Antonio Brown you know I'm in this
just bad people everywhere so and then
Fox on the other side you know they put
Kanye on they cut out all his
anti-semitic comments and then you know
I posted on Instagram I really didn't
think there was going to be any other
side to this conversation I just thought
yeah I just said everybody unite we
shouldn't speak badly about any groups
not indians not police not you know
whatever and all of a sudden I'm getting
this your censorship guy you're this and
I'm far from a censorship guy I mean I'm
I'm interested to see what happens with
Elon and Twitter
um but I believe in free speech and um
It's just sad to see a guy with his
platform uh speak like this and endanger
so many people you know and for what
what does he get out of it I don't I
don't know do you think the
repercussions he got you know Adidas
Cuts ties okay that's got caught some a
couple billion dollars uh Balenciaga
Cuts ties Vogue and a winter Cuts ties
drop by CAA drop eyes lawyers all these
Spotify up you know their downloads are
you know decreasing and Spotify hasn't
made a decision to drop them yet they're
thinking about keeping him just like
they kept Rogan when Rogan was everybody
wanted him to be canceled restricted
from Instagram and Twitter
stadium shows canceled documentaries
shelved 120 million dollars of cash left
yesterday he said he's lost everything
and his net worth dropped 2 billion in a
day yeah what was the Tipping Point
because he set stuff for oh he wore the
White lives matter that drove a lot of
people insane when he wrote that a
couple weeks ago yeah but what's a
Tipping Point well you know everybody's
going to say it's it's it's the Jews and
we control everything and that's what
happened so
um you know I don't know what the
Tipping Point is and I you know I don't
believe he's I don't believe he's got
any financial problems and anytime soon
but
um you're not thinking about like doing
a GoFundMe
I'm just thinking if you want to come up
with the idea I paid him you know Kanye
was on Entourage I paid him like uh 1100
bucks so he probably still has that in
his that's all you had to pay him yeah
yeah I mean honestly they called us to
be honest so um that was how it worked
with all our cameos they came on so but
it was but everybody wanted to be on
yeah like that was the show to be on
yeah people probably would have done it
for free to be on this yeah well yeah
the only reason we paid whenever we paid
yeah yeah but I mean first year it was
impossible to get anybody you know Mark
Wahlberg I almost I didn't know if Mark
was going to show up for his cameo in
the first episode I remember and he was
the executive producer
are you coming are you this you got 1100
bucks for me I'm sure we were when we
started and then by season two people
started calling us but with Kanye look
it's a long road and we'll see how long
this lasts or whatever and again I'm not
trying to keep the guy down he's an
incredible Talent
um you know and I don't want to just see
him come out and go oh I'm sorry I'd
like to get my money back and um I just
you know you want to see someone be
educated and understand how dangerous it
is to lump people into groups and any
groups you know I you know he's got
problems with you know some Jewish music
Executives I'm sure there's a million
people who do but when he talks about
controlling the media Rupert Murdoch is
the biggest guy in the media by a
million [ __ ] miles he's not Jewish
and you don't normally say you know you
don't you don't here oh you had a bad
interaction with this Catholic guy you
know because these [ __ ] Catholics are
killing us I mean I don't know what
they're doing well so exactly it's sadly
and why it's so scary for for Jewish
people is we're such a small group and
somehow it always comes back and I've
been saying it for years you'll see
eventually the right and the left
somehow comes together and goes against
us and um and again I still I really
don't want to make it just about his
Jewish comments I think people speaking
hate about any groups you know speak out
against it I'm not saying he should be
off Twitter I'm not saying he should be
off Instagram or anything else but I'm
not gonna go see his concerts you know
and I have I have before I think I think
it all started going downhill when when
Trump was in he started wearing the Maga
hat and that's where all the publicity
and everything came in but what makes it
like weird is that you don't you don't
see oh I've never seen somebody so
influential somebody's a billionaire
person with such a platform that has a
mental illness that people like TMZ
everybody they just want to see him in
here yeah you know what I'm saying
they're just like put them in front more
and more and more more if you're going
TMZ right now it's just him yeah well
everybody will put him on would you put
them on who him yeah absolutely yeah so
I mean you know I I put them on I'd put
them on our podcast if he wanted to come
on I won't give him a bag but yeah the
biggest the biggest thing is is you know
guys have made comments before
anti-semitic comments before so for me
when you hear comments being made you
know and and you sit there and you watch
it like okay Jimmy Kimmel Still's got a
show and back in the days you know hey
Howard Stern is a rock star and you want
to see what Howard Stern did one time as
a skit years ago he's still got a 600
million whatever's on massive contract
so there's the the hypocrisy is what's
the most annoying thing I do think it's
times and I'm never gonna say blackface
is okay or something but I can tell you
when I was a kid and I never put on
blackface there's no pictures of me I
wanted to be Eddie Murphy so badly when
I was a child that I I would dress up as
Buckwheat for Halloween now I did not do
blackface but I can tell you I when I
was a 12 year old kid I had no idea that
this would offend people and what and
Howard Stern again I'm not going to
defend Howard Stern but you know Robin
has been his partner for 30 40 years and
I think Howard Stern is a liberal I so
part of it is you know whether you're
doing art whether it's good art bad art
that's a whole different issue than when
you as a person go I have a problem with
this group of people I have a problem
with Indians the last three years
everybody's telling me they got a
problem with white people I mean they're
not being canceled yeah you got people
talking about they got problems with
whiteness and you know all these and I'm
not even white I'm Iran onion I'm in the
middle I'm not black I'm not white I'm
probably the one that gets targeted more
being a guy born and raised in Iran but
you hear these comments being made about
whites ah it's totally fine but you hear
the comments being made about the other
side oh my God so I understand what
you're saying I'm not saying to I
actually didn't make the comment about
Kimmel about him getting canceled I
don't think he's gonna get canceled I
don't think Howard needs to get canceled
I don't think I'm glad Rogan didn't get
canceled they almost try to get that guy
get canceled and Spotify stood behind
him and then eventually they didn't so
with Kanye here he's pushing the
envelope
extremely like to to say a comment what
was the comment to use uh uh he says I'm
gonna go
yeah yeah that's not I can't do that
kind of show you can't but but by the
way the way you handle that yeah is the
way musk handled it and he called him he
says hey what are you doing yeah and
they had a conversation I just had a
conversation with Kanye he seems sincere
and you know he's going to work on this
area and boom he kept him on he didn't
get worse I mean he got worse he goes on
everything and and says worse stuff and
again I'm not suggesting who should
cancel and the question is which I was
talking to some friends last night about
it I mean Adidas the company has fallen
apart as is and this was an enormous
Financial loss for them so I'm sure
forgetting their Nazi past which they
have which is the founder to me is
somewhat irrelevant you know because
it's it's I don't believe in the sins of
your father should be on this but I'm
sure there were terrifying discussions
inside this company and people who are
going to lose their jobs and people have
to feed their families and all that
stuff so it's hard for me to just go you
know put myself in a position oh you
know what I can make 100 million dollars
today with Kanye or I can just go you
know what I'm gonna make a stand but
I I'm glad that they did and I don't
think that's cancel culture I think
that's going I don't want you out in
front of my company spewing this
nonsense and this garbage and again I
don't and I understand as an Iranian
what you're saying but the sad thing is
with the with all the comments when they
come after white people and Howard Stern
who I is one of my favorites I mean
Howard he used to have Daniel Carver on
the racist and the Jews were always the
lowest group we were below everybody so
the weird thing is we kind of look like
we're white but then we're not really so
we get into this group where everybody
comes after us and and you know but
again I'm just trying to say as as corny
as it sounds it's like enough grouping
any group together there's do you have a
problem with a Jewish guy or an Iranian
guy that's your problem with him 100
that's it so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]